okay uh suppose let's talk about
setbacks here uh briefly and setback is
when uh you experience
uh something that you don't want to
happen it comes along uh unexpectedly
and uh and there it is it's it's in your
life so setbacks can be tiny setbacks uh
like when you uh go down to have
breakfast and realize that you're out of
yogurt that's a setback
you can have middle-sized setbacks like
when you go to leave for work and find
out that your car is out of gas
bigger setbacks you can break a leg
slipping on the ice really big setbacks
you can get a phone call from your
doctor and says well you know they the
biopsy came back and you know the story
unfolds from that of course the ultimate
setback is your own death that's such a
big setback that it seems silly even to
refer to it as a setback because it's
the ultimate setback
so those are examples of uh setbacks and
when one of them happens there's a
number of different frames you can put
around it so it's like the picture it's
like somebody said okay here's a picture
and this picture is going to be part of
your life and then uh question is but
we'll let you frame it
um so what are you going to do you're
going to pick the frame
that will make this picture that you're
going to have to live with
not just an acceptable picture but even
a beautiful picture
uh and so what stoic will do is he has a
list of frames he can choose from these
are psychological frames so he can he
can do the the
the victim frame this is what a lot of
people do when they experience a setback
in life what they do is they say i'm the
victim i'm a victim
and uh
and a woe is me and everybody take pity
on me
uh and uh you probably know people who
uh play the frame that do the the blame
frame very quickly and play the role of
victim
um
there's another way you can frame it
though you can say well i'm not a victim
i was the target
of some injustice
but i refused to play the role of victim
so what does a target do a target
attempts to bounce back a target
attempts to minimize the amount of harm
that was done
a target attempts to even be stronger as
a result of what happened and if you
think about
our great
cultural heroes right
they weren't people who uh played the
victim of a game they were people who
played the target game
so you take somebody like uh martin
luther king right if in response to uh
the injustice he experienced the racism
he experienced
if he had said hey everybody look at me
look at how depressed i am about all of
this and and it just isn't fair
boohoo who
we wouldn't be talking about him now we
wouldn't have a day that celebrated him
but he didn't do that he played the
target game used the target frame he
said
okay this is what's happening to people
like myself and a lot of other people as
well
and what we need to do is come up with a
way to respond to this
okay
so don't take pity on me
but listen to me
and listen to what i'm suggesting
so that's one of the frames and uh it's
very useful and i have
i'm a teacher college teacher i have
students who will come in late in the
quarter and they will tell me about
their lives and some of them have quite
complex lives
and i'll make it very quickly i'll make
it as clear as i can that i refuse to
pity them
that life has handed them a challenge
i will help them meet and overcome that
challenge but i refuse to take pity on
them and if they think they're somebody
deserving of pity
then we need to talk i offer to buy them
lunch
because um that shouldn't be the case
you know
people should
have some resilience and sometimes they
come from difficult backgrounds and and
you know you don't get to choose your
own parents and things that can can
happen
but the sooner you can leave that stage
of life and move on to the next stage
where you're you're the hero in your own
life
meaning all sorts of
bad even tragic things are happening to
you but you're dealing with them in a
heroic manner
wow
wow
uh
so i mean this is this is very powerful
so it's the same
situation
but
the way you process where you frame it
dramatically changes
how you feel about it what you do about
it what you think
about it
wow
you know it's something i've come to
really believe and i think
i thank the child that i was who went
through whatever he did because
somewhere along the way he decided
no matter what he was not going to be a
victim
and look i went through stuff that i
could literally point to say a victim
victim victim right
and
but look that doesn't that holds me back
but if i decide i want to be the hero
like what do i do i take
whatever is there and i own it and i let
go
you know it's like
like whatever happened happened but what
i was left from it whatever the
emotional charge what i'm carrying with
it that's mine
you know like it's not like someone gave
me that emotional charge i created that
emotional charge
and so i'm the one who's gonna free
myself and if i free myself i become the
hero of that story that's simple man i
can be the hero of any story in my life
all i gotta do is free myself and the
only one who can free me is me
you know only we can be the heroes of
our stories you know and it's something
that
it's
and it's makes it's made me better by
taking responsibility for everything in
my life and when i say responsibility
for everything in my life i mean
everything internal
you know i i really believe everything
starts with the internal and goes to the
external so i think responsible for
every single thing every single feeling
every single emotion every single thing
that happens inside
you know i was reading um
[Music]
this guy uh this christian mystic
earlier this year neville goddard and i
came across a quote and he said
god acts the devil reacts
so if you think about it you can either
choose to act or react
right and that's where actually that
line is on where do you want to be the
victim of the hero yeah if we choose
make a conscious choice and act i'm
going to free myself and i'm going to
let this go
you're acting if you're reacting
reacting is almost often pain
yeah right
yeah and it's it's a
it's giving away your sovereignty it's
giving away your personal power
and to who
to
that's the thing to do yeah yeah exactly
that's the most ridiculous thing right
yeah it's all it's been ours all along
it's only ours it's our foundation we
just have to give back to it
yeah it's it's and i think you mentioned
this in the book as well it's shifting
your orientation from things are
happening to me
to realizing that you're happening to
things by your own choices of your own
attitude leslie viktor frankl says the
last of the human freedoms is our
ability to choose our attitude towards
any given situation like it's you taking
back control he was in [ __ ] oh my god
yeah you know like if he's in auschwitz
and he's taking control of his attitude
he's happening to auschwitz
as much as auschwitz is happening to him
and that's what saved him that's what
saved that attitude
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you